I have great confidence in my
intelligence people but I will tell you
that President Putin was extremely
strong and powerful in his denial - and
coats came to me and some others they
said they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be the Senate
should have been I don't see any reason
why it wouldn't be Russia I have full
faith and support for America's great
intelligence agencies I accept our
intelligence community's conclusion well
the president today with a written
statement he read in the meeting with
Republican lawmakers ahead of talking
about taxes and what's next there he
tweeted yesterday coming back on Air
Force one as I said today and many times
before I have great confidence in my
intelligence people however I also
recognized that in order to build a
brighter future we cannot exclusively
focus on the past as the world's two
largest nuclear powers we must get along
this is all reaction to Helsinki a lot
of reaction from Capitol Hill and
elsewhere let's bring in our panel
matthew cottan any editor in chief of
the washington free beacon Susan page
Washington bureau chief at USA Today and
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist okay Matthew it was clearly a
cleanup effort after seeing the pushback
and the reaction what about it well I
think the fact that we had this walk
back is an acknowledgement of the
political firestorm the president from
comments Unleashed and it's not just
Trump critics of which there are many
but it's people like Newt Gingrich it's
people that you would consider more
friendly to Trump and so he clearly
understood that he needed to say
something to address the damage for me
though when you look at back at the
summit as a whole there's a real
question about what if anything was
accomplished there doesn't seem to be
much in the way of any concessions
President Trump made to Vladimir Putin
nor any progress on some of the major
contentious issues so if you're in the
White House today you're probably
wondering what it
go through the minority leader and
Lindsey Graham also talking about
possibly hearings going forward ticklish
we need hearings as soon as possible to
assess what President Trump might have
committed to President Putin in secret
president Trump's public statements were
alarming enough
I don't mind meeting with our
adversaries Russia is definitely an
adversary but I want to make sure that
we're being informed as to what any
potential agreements were made jeanne
shaheen even suggesting a senator from
New Hampshire that the translator should
be subpoenaed or called up to Congress
to testify
you know presidents have met privately
with other leaders before but this
reaction to Helsinki has it's a
different level and it was meeting with
with Putin for more than two hours it
was doing so without even a note-taker
present so it's not it as you say it's
not unprecedented for a president to
meet in private with a foreign leader
but this was a pretty extraordinary
circumstance and then to have that
continuity I think raised a lot of
questions about what exactly happened
there he's you know he didn't walk it
back try to walk some of it back today
but he didn't walk all of it back he
walked back one statement out of several
controversial statements and he did it
kind of walk back with a half twist
because he said I believe with the
intelligence agencies when they conclude
that it's Russian meddling and maybe
other people also which is not the
conclusion of US intelligence agencies
Mullen I agree with Matthew that out of
this summit we didn't see that much of a
change in policy but it's also true that
our relationship with Russia is at a
significant low point we're just having
some conversations can lead us to a
better outcome and there are so many
important things that they are involved
with that we care about whether it's
Syria Ukraine North Korea or nuclear
arms it's also what I'm kind of
surprised there's been this much angst
over this press conference not that he
said things the way he should have he
president Trump really did mess up with
that press conference but I don't quite
know what people want like he actually
is pretty tough on Russia and in the
last couple of years we've seen an
increase in the military brush budget
we've seen an increase in the
intelligence budget we're doing NATO at
your sizes in the Baltics we are we
provided lethal aid to Ukraine and
Georgia we're developing low-yield
nuclear weapons we've implemented
sanctions that were even stronger than
when we required by congressional
mandate so if you care about actual
actions
I think it's there's a lot to be happy
about in terms of a tough posture toward
Russia people are obsessed about words
and they should maybe focus on the
actions as well okay here is Congressman
Tom Cole and how his reaction to all
this it was the last president not this
president who told Russian leaders that
he would be more flexible after an
election it was the last president not
this president that said Russia was not
a geopolitical threat and chastised Mitt
Romney when he raised it in the campaign
and it was the last president not this
president that drew a red line and then
refused to enforce it Matthew I guess
that most that we heard today on Capitol
Hill was that he should the president
should have made those comments in front
of Vladimir Putin to tell him knock it
off or you can't do it again or what we
talked about privately I'm not going to
go over this again here but we have an
understanding that this is over or
behind us we don't know what was said in
the private meeting and I think if you
look back and president Trump's history
of diplomacy
I think he's much more willing to be
harsher in the private settings at least
with these authoritarian leaders than he
is in the public ones what did people
want
I think people wanted that the president
not necessarily equate the opinions of
his own Director of National
Intelligence dan coates with those of
Vladimir Putin that was I think the
major mistake the moral equivalence
exactly that sense of moral equivalence
I think only leads President Putin to
think that he has more of a free hand
when it comes to intruding and meddling
in our elections in the cyberspace I
think President Trump has been very
effective in reestablishing deterrence
and a lot of security areas visa vie a
lot of our enemies or competitors but
it's where it comes to cyber intrusions
and election meddling where I think he
may have led a blind spot with his
remarks yesterday well I said a couple
of weeks ago that occasionally I would
do
to hear from the late great dr. Charles
Krauthammer on different issues here's
one of them
a lot of countries try to influence
American elections we try to influence
elections among our democracies Israel
being a prime example but Russia is a
special case because it's an adversary
working against us Putin is not a friend
of the United States and being a good
well-trained KGB agent he lies with a
smile nothing like that happens without
the state in Russia he knows it we know
it but he he's a very good liar and
Trump when he is in office he's gonna
have to send a clear message to his fled
Vladimir friend Vladimir this can't be
done without consequences so whether the
clear message is sent as Molly says with
policy and actions or whether it needs
to be said rhetorically in front of him
is the question that some Trump
supporters are debating you know there's
a there's another question I think that
people would like to hear from president
Trump and that is a more full throated
embrace of our democratic friends our
allies than an authoritarian adversary
and I think one of the things that made
this press conference so distressing to
some people is that it came on the heels
of these difficult the difficult NATO
summit and the in the castigation of
Vangel barrage meant of Theresa May I
think it left him the impression that
President Trump was dissing our allies
with whom we shared democratic
traditions and in favor of embracing
someone who does not have a democracy I
will say the president sometimes and he
was as a candidate but he does sometimes
live in the moment now and you know like
that was them this is now this is what I
think I said and this is what we should
use going forward and it's particularly
challenging for him because he's been
sort of all over the place he will
concede that Russians meddled in the
election and then when he feels that
other people are conflating that
meddling with collusion treasonous
collusion
then he'll dismiss the whole enchilada
and he he needs to be understanding that
he just because other people play that
game doesn't mean that he gets to and he
needs to be more clear he did say today
in that little statement that they that
they are working very hard to keep
meddling from happening in 2018 and now
is a great thing that would have it
would have been good to say that at the
previous moment